inside the Hong Kong protesters fortress
police scour the corridors for almost
two weeks pro-democracy demonstrators
barricaded themselves inside this
University this is what they left behind
classrooms and halls are littered with
rubbish rotting food and hastily
abandoned supplies for the fight which
specialist teams now pick through
looking for dangerous weapons we have
two objectives today the first one being
the handling or the dangerous items such
as the petrol forms or offensive weapons
etc second second it would be the
evidence gathering procedure in relation
to all the crime scenes like criminal
damage etc but not but not we are not
trying to search any person armed with
petrol bombs and bows and arrows
activists fought for days on end with
the walls of police that hemmed them in
the battle for control of this
university is a defining moment in all
those six months of anti-government
protests here the greatest challenge to
the Chinese Communist Party under
strongman Xi Jinping and now a further
blow as double trump made law
legislation effectively backing
pro-democracy protesters in Hong Kong
and banning the export of tear gas
rubber bullets and stun guns a move
celebrated by Beijing's opponents as
president signed on the Hong Kong human
rights and democracy Act that's the
remarkable achievement of all the Hong
Kong's with the courage and
determination of Hong Kong is to fight
for freedom and democracy to start the
protest movement on June it just
encourage world leaders around the world
and politician aware that it's time for
them to stand with Hong Kong still
trying to negotiate the end of the
ongoing trade war the US president said
he signed the bills out of respect for
President Xi and the Hong Kong people
who he hoped would settle their
differences but China's already told
America to butt out and warned there
will be consequences
the trading relationship between Hong
Kong in the United States which is a
most favored nation kind of relationship
could be held hostage to all kinds of
political considerations in the Congress
in the White House that Hong Kong would
not like to see and could be very
damaging for Hong Kong six months in
there is no end in sight for Hong Kong's
demonstrations a protest that once
divided a city is now sending divisions
around the world
Shiva Robbins Sky News